عانى الاتحاد السوفياتي في الشرق
كارثة غير معروفة مبتدئ
وصل من كل مكان سنزوره
نجا طفل صغير فقط
أكثر منه رهباننا
الآن كبر ويتحدث غير معروف
لغة النظام على وشك
الجير الكبير لبوريس دونيفسكي
البس خاباروفسك فوربي وأنت
لي الروح إيريكا هل لديك لي على الانستغرام
وقعت
نعم انت تعرف نعم بالطبع
الجماعات
أنثى
يمكنك
أنت لا تتدخل في إطلاقها عليك
يبتعد
ما زلت بوريس على الحصير آيات لنا سخيف
givin dahin لذلك على kol
أنت ترسم عين كي تضاجع حنبلي
مليونير لاكوست
جيانلوكا فاك اتصلت به من أجل أو
لتحديد مكان التثبيت و
أو لن أكمل الإجابة عن العلم ونذهب
العالم
وهكذا ولد تيار مثل ما هو عليه الآن
من المألوف أن أقول مينسك
بخار غوستري برايت دي بوريسبول السحيقة
حسب حقيبته ، اذهب إلى روسيا بنفسك
الكولين جميع إيبيزا يحب إلياسوف
كيف يمكن الحصول عليها في الخلاصة كيف يمكن ذلك
الحصول على راتب بسيط الملابس آزر
بطالة وأنا وعملي ليس أرضية الله و
تسمح الآن وعندما تحمل عمدا
التسوق في غضون ساعة لا يمكن أن يكون كثيرًا الآن
مشاكل مع هذا المقهى ثم الآباء و
حتى 43000 حذاء للشراء
قد يعتني بنفس مثل هذا الشخص
ربما في عجلة من أمرنا لتبديد 44 قليلا إلى 8 و 6
ناقص 3 وفر 50 بالمائة من المشروبات مثل لي
أمي تعرف كيف تنظر وتوفر المال
[موسيقى]
ن في المنزل نمت أيضًا روبي هول بوريس
فيلم محليه المتفرج
ومهاجمة دوكاتي روج لا يزال لدي بيكاسو
مزرعة وليس من أجل أنا الفنلندي ولكن قاتمة
من هم بوريس كايلي كلاهما هايالي
[موسيقى]
لدي فأر كلب هنا
رموز جورجون
[موسيقى]
الدوقات بوريسبول هاوية هذا التوفيكو
ماموتا أزياء خطة باتيل
لكنني لست حبة الفول ، الخزنة ليست مالحة.
وها هي نظارات الصمام الثنائي مثل Karl Lagerfeld
الجميع لا يجعله بين
النجاح مع بوريس مقابل 10 رواتب واستلام
رأس أو
وجميعهم على الأقل يقفون حتى يسقطون
نتوءات غريبة عندما يتسرب شخص من هذا القبيل
تكلم
x الصغيرة بالنقاط
كن أنيقًا بعمر 74 عامًا وتأنق
وافق على أن هذا يمثل تحديا للبعض
يقيد التخريب بينما بوريس 8 من قبالة
السكتات الدماغية أو 7
أنا أتحدى الصور النمطية للعمر
فيلم وأجد نفسي أنيقة
حسنًا ، اغتسل ووفقًا لما هو معروف في روسيا
المطبخ المحلاق في سن المراهقة واللباس
نعم قبيح ، حسنًا ، ما كبرت
[موسيقى]
بعد كل ذلك
المزيد من wf و demenkov
عندما يحياك الناس
لم يترك أصدقاؤهم هذا هو الجيل
الثاني قادم
والشخص صعب بالفعل مع ذلك الماضي ، نعم
المقصورة العامة
وأنا ، على سبيل المثال ، ليس بالأمر السهل
المراهقون لا يفهمون الملابس الداخلية
وعلى أي بوريس حول الشكل ولكن السير يرسم
هولمز والدك
الخضار واللحوم على ملصق Great us
الطاووس بشكل عام ، أعطِ تفكيرك
الفيلم بالفعل هناك يا طبيعة بوريس
وهنا أندرو هذا ليس جملة
يفهم
و la-la من زوجي سعيدة بالموت حتى الآن
لا يوجد شيء من هذا القبيل هولي بوريس
نفس أمعائي الدقيقة أخشى من الجري بسرعة
لن تقبل
كانوا يدخنون باربوتو يعاقب الثعلب مع الو
الشعر والآن الملف
الجميع يحب الذكريات ولا احيا وانا
رمى كل شيء كما لو كان كذلك
ذهب كل شئ
فقط إلى الأمام الحقيقي
حتى المستقبل لتخمين الحاضر
[موسيقى]
اختيار السارماتيين وحقيقة يرتدون السعر
حتى تتم الأعياد
[موسيقى]
حصلت عليه كما يقولون
بعدا مختلفا قليلا مثلها
من خلال النظرة الزجاجية كما ابتسمت ابتسامة عريضة الشركات
[موسيقى]
أنا معجب بك الشخصية قد تغيرت بطريقة ما
دعاية منذ العام
الأصدقاء وبشكل عام هذا شيء آخر
الرجل الذي أنا هناك وبوريس يحب فيدور الأول
السعي
حسنًا ، نعم ، يتم تقديم الأرز مارات التوت
حضن
هذا الصباح وفقط
[موسيقى]
أبلغ من العمر 7 سنوات عند رؤية الدم ثم التوجيه حتى أنا
مقر توباك توبين برجر أعمدة أو
بوريس
الساحر الشاب نفسه الفيلم بدون هتافات
اتجاه
[موسيقى]
وليمة مجد الفولكلور و
بالفعل استراح حوالي 2 من القطط البلوط على النهج
أنا بنفسي يجب أن أقاتل حتى المخبأ ، أنا أيضًا
0 5 كتيبة كوشي السكر حقا ss
ألبينا كلا بوريس
بواسطة usb id لا موضوع الفولكلور الهراوة
عبده
مانتيسا تعلن أن إنستغرام لا يزال علمًا
الأسد أليس أليشر
هذا هو جل كافر ذكي لنا ملصق أنا أبحث عنه
فيكتور كازاكوف وحده وتلك كيروف ش
صديق
سالي ألقى الدفاع في سلة المهملات
مدلك ألما الويبرنوم دون
هنا المؤسسات الصناعية للغابات و
هذه المؤسسات هي من نوع النظام المناخ
معروف العمل القاسي انها قاسية
لذلك ، لدى الناس قناعتان ل
ثلاث قناعات
ولكن أن نقول أن لدينا أناسًا
أنا هنا أسوأ من غيري ولا أستطيع أن أقول هذا
أستطيع ذلك لأنه لن يكون صحيحًا
والمنتصر لديه أي بوريس أليس مولان
برمودا ، أنا ذاهب إلى نموذج هذه الطائرات
الموحد والمحلة انت
متشائم عليا وأنا أصفير الخضار أو
بدون ديف معي في الشاعر ولكن على الفور العد
ذهبت إلى متاجر التوفير أو بالأحرى
نظرة من جهة ثانية هناك هذا الأبيض
العباءة التي يعلقها ويتم تخفيضها إلى أقصى الحدود
لأن السود يأخذون الملابس البيضاء
هذه العلامة التجارية لطيفة ويتم دفعها إلى أقصى الحدود
لكني رأيت أن السعر مشروط نوعًا ما
يعتقد اسمحوا لي أن آخذه إلى المنزل
جاء الأريكة بدا
أعتقد أنه يمكن ترتيبها على هذا النحو
قبض على الجيش الأحمر
30 جرام
فيلم فيكتور الخوف وأنا البلطي
اترك دورة واحدة
هذا ما فعلوه في الشتاء في المكتبة
أنا جالس على جهاز الكمبيوتر الخاص بي ، سأحضر المكتبة
كمبيوتر محمول وهناك مما يعني أنه wi-fi
الإنترنت المجاني مجاني هناك
أجلس في المنزل مثل كل الناس يجلسون لساعات
ساطع نعم غير آمن إلى حد ما مع
على دراية بالكمبيوتر أمر صعب للغاية
تقنية ومثيرة للاهتمام للغاية
أنا أيضًا فيكتور فومين هول ، نعم ، نعم ، ونامين
أعتقد التفتا بلدي أركاديا وبطريقة ما ألفا
التبغ للكلاب
ما زلت هنا لمدة ساعة على النهر اثنين
كان العام في العام الذي كان فيه المنزل
حضاره
مغلق ولكن هذا إذا لم يعمل الحمار
جذب هنا لقد قطعت على النهر اثنين
سنوات مع الجميع
كل انتيل يوشكو لدينا له هناك و
هذا ملحق حلال 5
هذه ليونيانا كولا شاين واحد لماوليا
على مر القرون
هذا في العدسات العامة لفيلم أرتيم
تم تمكينه
لم أكن طبيعيا وعلى مفاتيح الجائزة
لي بعشر دورات وطرق
سأدخل أو رمي
لذلك فهمت بالفعل
من الصعب على الملحق ، إنه نفس الشيء بالنسبة للغرفة التي تحطمت فيها
0 بيانات من ميدان التدخين يوليا له
موقد المنتصر هذا يعني أنني سأقوم بسحق الماء
ساغري أنا أستحم كل يوم تقريبًا
ماء ساخن
لإبقائك على قيد الحياة
المتقاعد سكا وهو مثل هذا الأكورديون و
حمام
[موسيقى]
الأريكة البطاطس لها عراف قطرة بئر
لتحلق نعم فيكتور موقع إلى المشاغبين
علموا أن بجانبهم ، إذا كان البيض
الاعتراف لبعضهم البعض
وصوفيا لديها ضعف باريس لدينا
ساموراي حمام وزهر للسينما وسجل
بدا أليس بعد المنزل بعد ذلك
هنا الثقافة مغلقة
نوادي المصانع ومكتبة في كثير
بدا السكارى رغبتها
العمال ثقافة وقدامى المحاربين بعد ذلك
نحضره إلى القبر ، ولكن بطريقة ما يجب علينا
قاومها وأنا هنا
إلى حد ما تقاوم الأسماك
مجلس فيكتور المادا
ستذهب السفينة البخارية إلى السينما وإلا فسوف يمرض
من الإصابات في يامال وخسرت عملي
الزهور و tabbert
هتاف الحرية تعني الحرية أولا
تحويل الحرية في الأفكار المحددة في الملابس
لكني أعتقد وأنا فنية طوال حياتي
لقد قادت جزءًا منها الآن سأقوم بخياطة الصفوف
واجهة فيكتور للسينما الجادة تايمز الحرية
طائفي ألفا حول يلوح في الأفق الصيفي
فيلم Finadin إلى biogel oil ayran للفيلم
الطريق إلى الوطن نصف المحامين الشباب أو الذباب
كندا
وعلى المنتصر أو ماجوا ينتقل إلى فارس
جدي
في هاربين جمعة أليس وأجرة بولانوفا
ليكس Lyapin بدون وما شابه
تقاتل
[موسيقى]
مقاتل في جبهة الثقافة ، لكن يجب على المقاتل
تبدو مناسبة لسلاحك
سلاح glavnar هو الصوت
لون وخطوط ومثل المقاتل
الجبهة الثقافية حتى قتال مع ماذا
مع كل أنواع مظاهر الظلام
تارا فيكتور هو لي باستا و
بينما حتى في هذه القوة بمطرقة ولدينا
الملك عميد
بالنسبة لي يتلمس طريقك استعراض بحيرة واه
المنتصر هم أيضًا زبون راضٍ
أكلتك متكيفة ولوح على أثق
تيم شارب هافن أوبي وان نوم وفير
أو هاتف لا جريمة الجوز و
[موسيقى]
رؤية القضية ، قفز المثقفون و
في حالة سكر من الأدغال ولكن أيضًا مدروس بالطبع
على نفسي ولكن
لكن منذ ذلك الحين لمدة 20 عامًا كنت فيها حتى الآن
بقي من الذين هاجموا
ليس كل شخص على قيد الحياة وهذا بالفعل مع فيكتور أو
كتب الرائد عادة جسر الخلد
عسلي ونماذج ركوب و
ألدو مورو هكتار وارد أنا غابي
ليوبوتين
مثل صواريخ كاتيا كاتيا كاتيا كاتيا
اسمحوا لي أن أغني أغنية لماذا نعم بسبب
اننا طيارون والسماء هي سماءنا
المنزل أول شيء أول شيء
الطائرات
حسنًا ، فالفتيات والفتيات لا أستطيع
الشرب بدونك هو ملكنا
عميلنا المفضل
كان فيكتور خائفا من التمرد ومنش من Adzharia
أنا تعبت من تاجر دوران ديمون ذلك
أنا أعتبر دون تردد حتى لكم الخرز
لأن لدي واحدة ملكية
الزي وهناك أنا فقط
بالطبع هناك شيء للاختيار من بينها.
شراء ولكن أنت نفسك رأيت كل شيء في بيتي
تناثرت حولها
حسنًا ، أعتقد أنني سأقدم مقدمة
في أنا
لكن
[موسيقى]
أنا أشياء من أنا في الصيادون الذين أمشي بعد ذلك
أنت كيروف
العجاف أو الأمل أنا يساوي 1 الاتحاد و
يتصل
لقد جئت إلى هناك لكنهم اقتراحي
بطريقة ما دون إلهام لذلك
لم أفعل و
يضطر للجلوس في هيكتور للتصوير
على مصارعة ماما ، قابيل في سن الأربعين ثم الفيلم
حتى كاتي فيدا طويلة نقطع الجير
الخلافة والواجهة اللعينة هي بشراهة
و يخصني
جير
أكثر
[موسيقى]
نعم ، نحن كتبنا واحد وعمولاتنا سنويًا
أو طبيب نفساني
يسأل عن شخص لم يدرس على الفور
لماذا ليسوا بخير ليس كل شيء في المنزل
هناك بعض الأسئلة الغبية
اطلب ربطة عنق تتحدث معي
يقولون اللعنة إنه شخص رائع
[موسيقى]
أصلي إيغور بعض الوقت
إعادة تشغيل Holivar أهميتها
الحروف الهجائية
انها على biodme archmages والآن أنا على الخروج
من الدار تسقط أنت
[موسيقى]
دخلت خدمة الدعم لدينا
قالت مكالمة من المشتركين أن على أحد
تتسرب المياه من شوارع مدينتنا
[موسيقى]
هذه مغرة إيغور آيات
آيات هو كذلك وهجمات ddos ​​تقيسني
البيتلز مرة أخرى ديكو
بيل أصلي العجوز موس ومانويل
منسحب
[موسيقى]
إيغور وحده هذا جيلي ميلر
التليفون المحمول
لك معك موفاسة ثم طلمبات الجير
للصفقات
المدينة كلها تعرفني الأقراط الجميلة
يدفع للجميع مع خديه
على أرض باربي نحن مرة أخرى كارل لاغرفيلد
للأفلام بخصوص Good ya radu olya
مينيسوتا أديل
يكفي أولغا ، نعم ، اللعنة ، أنا خياطة
من أجل الروح ولا أستطيع العيش بدونها
اتصل من أجلك ملح 2014 نحن
ترعرعت في مسابقة ، جرّته إليها
اللباس
أكثر من شهرين و
في هذه اللعبة عالية سواء كنا نقف. فيلم
جانا فان باتالين فيريت ن في المنزل رميت
من يحتاج واحد والآن هو ومن 15
لأصبع القدم المداعبات لهم
أحمر شفاه صحي فكيف سيفعلون
ترسم قليلا وها أنت ذا
شك
بضاعة جاهزة زنبق ميلجاكا
الأقواس
هل فعلت
يرى الرجال
وضوحا نفس الإصدار البيج هود
كان علي أن اتصل بها هكذا
قماش قطني مطبوع
مواد
ايجور حانات متنقلة وصوفيا 1000
ساعدني في كل ذلك وفي أذني أصلي
أوقات الفيلم هي صوفيا
لمقابلة الرجال ، أنا أصلح الليم
شيء يمكنهم بعد ذلك إعطائي سيارة
إصلاح كل نفس هذا العمل
[موسيقى]
حسنًا ، لقد وضعت الخط للتو ، الشيء الوحيد المتبقي هو
قص الخيوط
وأعتقد أن فيتالي سيكون سعيدًا
المغرد فيتامين ج والآن لدي 100 صندوق
سأضغط من إيغور
حسنًا ، سأخبرك بالمزيد وهو ببساطة ضخم
هذا واحد يعمل كثيرا ولكن جدا
يأخذك شيء لم ينجح
افعلها مرة أخرى
صعب جدا والناس لا يفهموننا
أن برام سيأخذك ألف سيدة
الآلاف وضعوا بعض الكاذبة
المواد المضافة ، دعنا نقول أنها بكرات على الخزان
طاغية هذه العناوين
أثناء النهار أبحث عن العملاء وفي الليل أجلس و
أنا أطرز هذه الفساتين
هذا ما تطرزه للتو وفقط في الصباح
استيقظ مثل الثالثة في الصباح التفكير
حسنًا ، فقط أغمض عيني
هناك اقتباسات وأنت تستيقظ بالفعل
يمكنك أن تقول الكذب على هذا التطريز
الناس يقعون من أجله
ستائرهم وبطولاتهم للإيذاء والسكك
أنا أتحمل الشكوك حول ما إذا كان البعض مني على هذا النحو
كتب دونا سقف اللحام أو مجموعة
حل هذه الغابة الكثيفة من الدعاوى 11 دولة
وحدة مكتب جوليا
بشكل عام ، كانت المهمة هي صنع فستان
بالنسبة لدرجة وولاند ، فهي شفافة ، أي
إذا
خلع الفستان السفلي
ثم اتضح عمليا
محيطات عارية من أجل d & g
والأسود عبارة عن شرائح فقط في العالم 0 قبل الميلاد بالذكاء الاصطناعي
تي ليزا بوم بيبي للجسم يمكننا أن نفعل الشيء نفسه
الساعة 12 صباحا يخرج بسترة برتقالية اللون
وذلك أيضًا مع وجود شريط حول الرقبة وعليه
hayato igor tom on end on alina and i k
المزيد من الوقت بالنسبة له
لكنني الآن أقوم بالتركيب الأول لفستان
أنا أجمع الخطوط
تم إعطاء إغلاق مركز شبه منزلق
لحظة ما لدينا
ضخ المياه من البئر
أنا أبحث الآن لذا دعنا نقول أن لديها توازن
يوجد خط الخصر على الظهر وعلى الرف
لدينا مثل هذا الجهاز
محلل الغاز قبل النزول
في بئري دائما
اخفضها وابحث عن وجود الغاز
هو هناك على الأقل
هذه . ضد
تم تخزينها هناك خياران لهم
لنا السفن على مائل
الفرنسية الحقيقية
أكثر
وهل تالما تحب شكواي
جيرسا ونعم كان لدي نفس الفيلم الذي يمسح
خلال المنافسة
طفل فيانا المدينة
إغلاق بئر الماء اثنين
الصمامات
الأمل الجاف أن تسرب ستيلا
والنقر على هذا الشرطي بعد ذلك
فرضية من خلال رمي والقتال حتى ufa
ديكور عنيف من نفس العالم نازيرو في الصورة
وتلده من أجل التوراة البيضاء لهم
الظلام وكذلك بوب